hello and welcome to this video playing
I am Michele Michele Mackay I'll go poof
ok it's always the tick of are getting
very that they might play that the
exchange variation okay the t3 line this
is one of those lines where I feel ya I
don't really know it when enough
basically making things up over the
board which is not which is not
appropriate this line is Sir really
quite dangerous with d3 but okay I hope
I'm managed with normal moves or more
Molly booze with kind of most that look
normal to me yeah this is this is how
they play and some never really
understood how this yeah but the point
is of all this not meaning in a bad way
i mean i'm not selling saying he's
playing badly or anything and probably
the opposite i just i don't understand
this kind of strategy that white is
playing him I've seen similar things in
Grand Master games and I never really
never really grasps [ __ ] why plays
before and then stir things like that
try to double them okay so I cannot take
before let's activate this we're good
don't think this is can be too bad mmm I
can almost take on a one night Queen
takes Knight see to screen a check
unfortunately check okay
yeah that's okay i think should be
should be fine for me doesn't have clear
way forward I wonder probably d5 yeah
maybe activate a little bit more hip f3
wow wow how do i mean i would like to
get my Bishop to b6 am NOT not sure that
it is possible though or the night I
maybe the night actually it's not doing
much either
yes but there's still the specially
resides yeah so two blunders and in the
first two games of this session to gross
blunders from positions bad wasn't
really necessary yeah why place this 63
line which is currently really
fashionable I have to say that I usually
just play it by ear which is not a good
thing yeah it's um this line is pretty
pretty serious business yeah this is how
they usually play it and often 95 yeah I
just plate normal-looking moosey I
expected 95 he returned he traded and
then played this this setup I have seen
some some have seen setups like that but
I never really understood what why does
after with it okay I try to play this a
5 him and I thought that that this
should be quite ok I mean I'm quite
active checked yeah yeah yeah it's a bit
unfortunate I thought yet should take
word I cannot do this Jack because of
the chick check ya here I felt that
should be ok but d5 yeah I know f3 was
surprising I thought you would probably
take or so and three looks weakening but
it's probably not so bad i don't--
relieved I don't have anything that I
can do directly with this week squares
this is what they are this is the engine
suggestions who are interesting
that invasion here interesting yeah
that's not so bad okay the computer
wants to Penn wants to take ok now ok I
see the point if this then I get very
nice squares especially c4 of course and
here check here this is actually winning
already because of whites weird piece
coordination and a king f1 and i have c
5 yeah ok that's a bit unfortunate
friend that you gave away the piece that
I mean why it was slightly worse because
of my I'm just a bit more active but
it's nothing particularly threatening I
guess ok thanks for watching